HBO's Game of Thrones closed out its sixth
season with arguably one of the greatest finales
in television history...and with one of the
most incredible revelations in the show's
run so far. Oh, and in case you couldn't tell?
Spoilers ahead...
Bran's vision confirms what fans have long
suspected: Jon isn't actually the bastard
son of Ned Stark. Instead, he's actually Ned's
nephew, the child of his sister Lyanna Stark.
This is huge! And here's why.
Half-Targaryen?
We didn't get to fully hear what Lyanna whispered
to Ned just before she died, but it seems
likely that her baby is the son of Prince
Rhaegar Targaryen. And this handy infographic
released by HBO a few days after the finale
would seem to confirm this fact.
Quick refresher: the war that made Robert
Baratheon king in the first place? It started
when Rhaegar apparently abducted Robert's
wife-to-be, Lyanna Stark.
But Bran's vision revealed that Lyanna gave
birth to baby Jon Snow in the Tower of Joy.
We still don't know for sure, but it sure
seems like maybe Rhaegar didn't abduct Lyanna,
but simply invited her to be his lover, and
she willingly accepted. If true, that means
Jon is the son of heirs from two noble houses,
the Starks and the Targaryens. That gives
him a claim to Winterfell and the Iron Throne.
If only Bran can give him the scoop on his
lineage…
Ned Stark's honorable dishonor
Ned Stark had to lie and say that he sired
Jon out of wedlock just to protect Jon's identity.
That brought dishonor to his name and made
his wife, Catelyn, think he'd cheated on her,
all to prevent King Robert from discovering
the infant threat to his new hold on the throne.
Ned also forced himself to keep Jon at a distance
to maintain his bastard status, despite him
being the only thing that remained of his
beloved sister. Don't forget Ned's last words
to Jon before he set off for the Night's Watch:
"The Starks have manned the wall for thousands
of years, and you are a Stark. You might not
have my name, but you have my blood."
Thanks, Uncle Ned.
A New Threat to Queen Cersei
We all know the newly-crowned Queen Cersei
is one of the worst villains of the series.
And with no more children left to appoint
as horrible rulers, the likely candidates
to usurp Cersei are Daenerys, Jon, or Petyr
Baelish—but only if he can convince Sansa
Stark to marry him. Nevertheless, Jon unknowingly
has a legitimate claim to the crown, and if
he can prove it, he could march his forces
southward, take the pointy chair, and stop
the invading White Walkers.
Will he marry Aunt Daenerys?
Being the son of Rhaegar Targaryen makes Jon
Snow Daenerys' nephew. Sorry to everyone hoping
for King Jon to marry the Mother of Dragons
in the end, but that's his auntie. That said...incest
was generally acceptable for the Targaryens.
But if Jaime and Cersei Lannister's twincest
has led to this many problems throughout the
Seven Kingdoms, we don't imagine a happily
ever after love story ending in a shallow
gene pool.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know what you think will happen in Game
of Thrones next...